redémarrez donc par le classement des
tops recherche google 2018 qui a été
révélé on vous résume tout ça en images
et vous allez voir que le terme chez les
jaunes
bien que datant du mois de novembre
rentrer directement dans le top 3 et
vous allez voir les deux premiers c'est
ouf
regardez comme chaque année google
publie les recherches les plus
fréquentes des internautes français sur
son célèbre moteur de recherche
et sans surprise côté actualité la coupe
du monde et les gilets jaunes arrivent
respectivement en première et troisième
positions des mots clés les plus
recherchés
quant à la deuxième position elle est
occupée par france gall disparu en
janvier dernier dans la catégorie
politique et société les gilets jaunes
arrivent là directement numéro un suivi
par les grèves sncf puis alexandre
benalla du côté des sportifs
antoine griezmann et didier deschamps
occupent les deux premières places du
podium suivi de très près par benjamin
pavard enfin on le sait google est notre
meilleure amie quand il s'agit de
répondre aux questions qu'on se pose
et cette année les français n'ont pas
manqué de faire appel au célèbre site
pour répondre à quelques questions
existentielles du type pourquoi des
semaines joue à manches longues et même
une question sur tes pmp pourquoi gâteau
coquilles tpm p enfin au top trois on
retrouve pourquoi les poilus bref tout
un tas de questions passionnantes et
pourquoi pourquoi gâter tout pépin paix
était numéro deux des recherches
voilà donc c'était à croire ça fait
plaisir qu'on parle de tpm paix et on
vous donnera agathe fait maintenant
partie de balances ton post être avec
nous d'ailleurs vendredi parce qu'on
sera en direct
en prime vous c'est quoi la russie objet
plus le fait ou sur google cette année
vous cherchez sur google vous comme
matthieu delormeau ou bien sûr monnerat
tango évidemment dont govou c'est quoi
vous c'était un truc autour des enfants
éducation a c'est vrai mais c'est ça
ouais ouais vous c'est point soleil dans
le quartier et mathieu c'est quoi moi je
tape mon nom je parle de leur menu de
leurs moque de nous n'a je regarde ce
qui sort et de l'envoi new day sur quoi
a mal de choses
barrière mon avis merci garder quoi sur
quand il a tapé sur le clou
je tape généralement valérie bénaïm nus
ce qui ressort je voulais être bas merci